SIERRA: on a scale of one to ten, how
strongly do you think we responded to 2016?
NANCE: Zero.
SIERRA: Oh. That’s—I
didn’t even have it on the scale.
NANCE: It’s not on the scale. It’s not
on the scale. We’re not prepared at all for
2020. The way Russia had attacked us was using
truths, half-truths, and lies as sort of like
information cruise missiles. And the air that they
glide on is the internet. The explosive payload
is the lie that’s embedded in there. And the
problem is, unlike a regular cruise missile
where the payload hits and explodes, this is
more like spreading a—you know, a virus.
SIERRA: Right, it’s like a rumor or a lie.
And once it’s out, even if you say it was
a lie or a rumor it can’t be put back.
NANCE: But it’s more insidious than a—just a
rumor or a lie. What was hacked in 2016 wasn’t
the Democratic National Committee; it was the
mindset of the American voter. And the way they
hacked it was to enter it, pour in misinformation,
allow you and your loved ones to spread the
virus. And now, completely infected, you refuse
to believe that anything is wrong with you.
SIERRA: Well, that’s bleak and scary. (Laughs.)
NANCE: (Laughs) I’m good at that.
SIERRA: Election talk can feel exhausting--hacking
and meddling and disinformation. But we have to
talk about it, because we got hacked in 2016,
hard. Not just our voter databases, and not
just the DNC email servers, but... us. I’m
Gabrielle Sierra, and this is Why It Matters.
Today, how Russia’s been hacking democracy,
and whether or not we’re ready for 2020.
SIERRA: All right. So let’s pretend that I
was just frozen in a block of ice and I have
no idea what happened in the 2016 election.
So what the heck happened in the 2016 election?
NANCE: Well, fundamentally what happened in the
2016 election is that the United States
carried out what we thought at the time
was a free and fair election.
SIERRA: This is Malcolm Nance,
a former Naval Intelligence officer and an
expert on national security and counterterrorism.
He’s also a regular contributor to MSNBC.
NANCE: But as we were coming into the election
season in April and May of 2016, we were
discovering that there was an intrusion at the
Democratic National Committee’s computer servers,
and that this intrusion was carried out by two
Russian intelligence entities. And what they
did was they penetrated the DNC’s servers,
stole all of their information, and
essentially carried out Watergate, but a—
SIERRA: Hmm. But a hacking Watergate.
NANCE: Right, a cyber Watergate. But why?
So Russia apparently carried out this attack
in order to spread information about the DNC,
use the emails which came from their servers,
and then used WikiLeaks, led by Julian Assange,
gave them all of these emails, and then let
them put them into the information stream
to essentially act like catnip for the global
media in order to damage Hillary Clinton.
PBS NEWSHOUR: The CIA and other U.S.
intelligence agencies have concluded,
the Russian government was behind the email
hack into the Democractic National Committee
and other political organizations.
CBS NEWS: Officials actually believe the
hacking of the DNC went on for more than
a year, starting back in June of 2015 as
part of a wave of cyberattacks into American
political and government institutions.
SIERRA: Because of all the news coverage, it can
be easy to think the DNC hack was the main element
of Russia’s election interference. But there
were two other major components. One, was the
spreading of disinformation on social media.
ROSENBERGER: What they did was essentially a
largely covert social media operation...
SIERRA: This is Laura Rosenberger. She’s
the director of the Alliance for Securing
Democracy and a senior fellow at The German
Marshall Fund.
ROSENBERGER:
...in order to pit Americans against each other,
sow chaos, create a more polarized electorate,
and as the intelligence community assessment has
concluded, undermine support for Secretary Clinton
and, support, President Trump's prospects.
SIERRA: The final piece, used alongside the DNC
hack and the spread of disinformation,
was the hacking of voter registration
databases. For this part we turned to
Joseph Marks who writes a newsletter
on cybersecurity for the Washington Post.
MARKS: The U.S. intelligence agencies would tell
you yes, Russia did interfere in the 2016 U.S.
election. That’s the conclusion of seventeen U.S.
intelligence agencies, of the Mueller report,
and of the Senate Intelligence Committee.
It was a multifaceted campaign. The major thing
they did from a cybersecurity angle was to
probe election systems probably across the country
but it was at least twenty-some states this was
noticed and recorded in. And it’s
probably all fifty, according to
the Senate Intelligence Committee and
other people who have looked at it.
They actually penetrated voter databases in
Illinois and may have penetrated systems,
in a couple of counties in Florida. There’s no
evidence that they actually changed any votes or
did anything once they got into those systems.
SIERRA: So even though they didn’t change
anything, having the access is the problem?
MARKS: Yeah. You don’t want Russia to have
access to your voter registration data or
to internal parts of your voting systems
—there are a couple of problems with that.
One, they could do something if they chose
to. And number two, just the possibility
of them doing it makes it easier both for
Russia or for people internally to
suggest that the result of the election
isn’t what it was supposed to be.
SIERRA: So that was their goal?
MARKS: Yeah, it was part of a broader
goal to sow chaos, create dissension,
show up American democracy as not working
as well as we always claim it does.
SIERRA: So they were super successful then.
MARKS: Yeah, in a lot of ways. I mean,
all of the chaos and the partisanship that
we’ve experienced, and the lack of trust
that the election came out well, the anxiety about
2020, that’s exactly what Vladimir Putin wanted.
SIERRA: Look, it’s impossible to say whether
or not Russia changed the outcome of the
2016 election. But what has changed is
the atmosphere surrounding elections.
Facts seem up for debate in a way that
they weren’t before. And this brings us to
disinformation.
ROSENBERGER:
So I think it's important to understand that
we use the term "disinformation" as a sort
of broad-sweeping, you know, all-encompassing
catchword. But in fact, the kind of things they
did weren't necessarily all what's classically
defined as disinformation. So for instance,
the Russian social media manipulators were very
active on issues of race. Racism in our country
is a real problem, and it's authentically
American, and it's a huge vulnerability,
and the Russians have taken advantage of that.
And so in 2016, and afterwards, what they did was,
you know, this was the time when the Black
Lives Matter movement was- was very active.
They created a lot of fake accounts.
SIERRA: One of those fake accounts portrayed
a fictional woman named Louisa Haynes.
ROSENBERGER: ...her handle was “Woke Louisa”.
She was supposedly a young
African American activist from
New York. She believed that Hillary
Clinton was a very bad candidate
on criminal justice issues, and thought that
African Americans shouldn't vote for her,
she was an account created by operatives in
Saint Petersburg at the Internet Research Agency.
But she actually not only spread
these views on social media
but actual traditional media outlets cited-
SIERRA: Oh my gosh.
ROSENBERGER: ... quote, "Louisa Haynes"
as an example of African Americans who
were concerned about Hillary Clinton's record on
criminal justice issues. And there's some great
research that was done by a professor out the
University of Washington named Kate Starbird,
she found large clusters in both the Black Lives
Matter conversation and the Blue Lives Matter
conversation of these fake Russian accounts.
They were pretending to be real Americans,
talking about these issues. And she found
that those accounts were doing two things.
One, they were either the most active and
prolific- of those clusters, or they were
pushing the most extreme and most polarizing
kinds of perspectives on those issues.
SIERRA:
Wow. And playing both sides.
ROSENBERGER: Absolutely playing both sides. And
I could go down a litany of issues, where we saw
the Russians, where we now know from the accounts
that have been released, that they were actually
weighing in on both sides of these issues.
SIERRA: Wow.
SIERRA: Okay, Russia is good at stirring
the pot. But why mess with U.S. elections?
What’s the goal?
ROSENBERGER:
So, Russia is an objectively declining power.
And that means that for Vladimir Putin,
he can't really use a lot of conventional tools
and strategies in order to grow Russia's power on
the world stage. For Putin, the things that matter
most are his own power, and, sort of, his own
security as a leader. And so, in order to actually
convince the Russian people that he's working to
restore Russia's greatness, his best approach is
to weaken his competitors, and to use a series
of asymmetric tactics in order to undermine and
weaken those competitors from within. You know,
Putin has understood, that sort of weakening the
foundations of democracy is a way of attacking
democratic countries, and hindering our ability
to effectively govern, to effectively carry out
our national interests by forcing us to, you
know, spend more time arguing with each other,
which we're pretty good at by the way in the
first place. So at this point, sometimes it's
just accelerant to the fire. But I think really,
that's the long-term strategy, is- is weakening
us from within.
NANCE:
Now we are in a Russia that is led by a former
KGB officer. He has—he knows that his ideology
is just money, but so is the Western ideology.
But he also has political goals that, in essence,
just means make Russia great again, right? And
to make Russia great, he clearly just looked
back at the Soviet model of how they spent
decades trying to destabilize the West and
bring down liberal democracies. And the way the
Soviets tried to do it was, you know, subversion,
paying off the Communist parties of each of these
countries, on occasion buying a politician and
trying to get them in a scandal. Putin realized
that those old methods were never going to work,
right? What you do is that you work within
these democracies by creating political
parties that are aligned with you, and you use
democracy to vote democracy out of existence.
And so what we saw was, in concert with
this political ideology, he was using
a new methodology on an old technique,
right? He was using information warfare,
but disseminated through social media, which
was now moving at the speed of a keystroke.
It is literally an attempt to realign the poles of
the world as they have existed since World War II,
which is where Russia becomes a major
strong—asymmetric, though—player,
even though they are a very poor country, you
know, which is led by an oligarchy through a very,
very severe autocrat.
SIERRA:
What are some interference scenarios
that we should be looking out for
heading towards 2020 that maybe we didn't
see in 2016 or have escalated since 2016?
ROSENBERGER: Yeah, so one of the things I'm
really concerned about is the hijacking of
activist's movements. I mentioned how we saw some
of this around particularly the Black Lives Matter
movement, before and after 2016. And that is one
thing I'm particularly concerned about for a few
reasons. One is that, by going after activists
you're often going after groups that feel already
that they may be disenfranchised in some way
or another. And so by hijacking these movements
it can actually serve to delegitimize them, and
we actually saw this, for instance, in France,
where the Gilets Jaunes movement, the yellow
vests. The Russians not surprisingly sort of
jumped on that movement, both on social
media and a little bit in the streets.
In order to, again, sort of discredit President
Macron, undermine, French democracy, you know,
just sow chaos, right?
SIERRA: Right, just a
drop and it poisons the well.
ROSENBERGER: Yeah, and to me that is
really dangerous because if activists are being
discredited just because the Russians hijacked
their movement, that, in certain scenarios,
can drive people even further to extremes,
those kinds of trends really, really worry
me. Another concern I have is that the kind of
cyber probes that we saw on election systems in
2016 could be repeated and could be potentially
coupled with a disinformation campaign. So the
cyber probes don't actually change anything,
but simply the fact of those probes
having occurred could be used to actually
dispute the results of the election.
SIERRA: This right here is the point. Once
you’ve been hacked, it’s hard to trust again.
The doubt sticks. A small cyber intrusion that
doesn’t change a single vote might still be
enough to get Americans to argue about who won.
And according to Joseph Marks, the hack wouldn’t
even have to hit voting infrastructure.
MARKS: If you get into an electric grid and affect
traffic lights in an urban area of a state but
not the rural area of a state, and it’s a swing
state, that could, uh, drive up Republican votes,
drive down Democratic votes, and deliver that
state for the Republican candidate. You could
shut down lights in a particular area that affects
the vote. You could do all sorts of things that
make it tougher for people to get out and vote.
And sow distrust in the system. And that also,
because we’ve been talking about the ways in
which Russia tries to play into divisions that
already exist, there’s a lot of concern
about voter suppression in this country.
You could play into that in a way that makes
people less likely to trust the outcome of
a particular race, whether it’s, you know,
congressional, presidential, or whatever.
SIERRA: So the idea is that I’d
be stuck at a traffic light and I
wouldn’t get to the polls before they closed?
MARKS: Yes. The idea that multiple people-
SIERRA: Lots of people.
MARKS: -would be stuck at traffic lights and
decide that it’s not worth voting or create the
perception that a lot of people decided that.
And if that’s what happens in one area that trends
Democratic versus Republican, or vice versa,
that could lead into a narrative that had
things happened differently the outcome of
the election would have been different.
SIERRA: Just enough doubt to get people
riled up and questioning the outcome. And if
it’s that easy to create division, how do we
ever recover? What can we do to unhack
ourselves and create a basis of trust?
MARKS: The number one thing that security experts
will tell you is paper ballots. Paper ballots,
or at the very least a paper backup that comes out
of the machine that the voter can look at and say,
yes, this is what I intended. And then you put
that in lockbox, and it’s there to be counted
afterwards. The second thing most people say
is risk-limiting audits, which is essentially
you look at the risks, you audit X
percent of ballots after the race to
make sure that what people mark is lining up with
what the, um, computer reads from those ballots.
And if there are any irregularities then you
keep doing it until you’re doing a full hand
recount. That’s the lion’s share of what states
and localities have been doing since 2016.
SIERRA: So you’re saying, technology has failed
us. (Laughter.) We’re going back to paper.
After that it’s raising our hands,
just nothing on the computer at all.
MARKS: Yeah, it’s - it’s ironic because
2019 and paper’s the safest thing,
but paper’s the safest thing.
SIERRA: But switching to paper
ballots isn’t the only step we could take.
ROSENBERG: We don't yet have robust enough
multilateral mechanisms to share information
either about threats and threat analysis,
or to share information about
responses, best practices,
lessons learned, what's working, what's not.
SIERRA: So we gotta break down silos from the very
beginning, from the platforms, to the government,
all the way through to everybody across the world,
talking about what's happening.
ROSENBERG: Yes. Breaking down
silos and creating more integrated and
coordinated and collaborative approaches,
underpin almost all of the responses, I think
we need to be taking to this problem set.
NANCE: The only way to defeat this is for
democracy to truly reassert itself. The greatest
disinfectant is truly sunlight. You have to talk
about it. You have to make it clear. And the
only way you can do that is you really are—we are
really going to have to take democracy seriously.
And I have no problem blowing the alarm. The
America as you know it and have known it and have
sat around and enjoyed for 243 years may transform
itself into an America you won’t recognize.
SIERRA: So how prepared are we for 2020?
ROSENBERGER: I think that we're certainly more
aware of the threats- we've certainly
taken some steps. I would argue that
none of that is sufficient. If anything the
country's just gotten more polarized since 2016.
The other thing, I would say on this, is that, you
know, candidly, this is a problem where we need
real strategic leadership from the top. And, we
need communication very clearly to the American
people about the threats that we see. And we have
not had that. And in fact, we've had what I think
are counterproductive messages on this, from
senior officials, including from the President,
about, you know, whether it's
inviting other countries to interfere,
or the idea that accepting foreign help in an
election is not something that's problematic.
SIERRA: Right.
ROSENBERGER: And frankly even casting doubt
on whether Russia interfered, right?
MARKS: You know, a lot of machines that did
not have paper ballots or paper backups in 2016
will have them in 2020. The Homeland Security
Department, which had visibility into just
a fraction of the digital happenings around
election systems in 2016 will have
visibility into close to 100 percent of it in
2020. State and local election officials who
didn’t know a whole lot about cybersecurity
before 2016 know a lot more about it now.
Those are all big and substantial changes.
Have we done as much about disinformation? We’ve
done less. People are tracking it. They’re paying
a whole lot of attention to it. Social media
companies are paying a lot of attention to it.
But there’s still certainly more to be done.
A point that some Homeland Security Department
officials sometimes make is part of this is just
about educating the public about what to expect.
And that’s really tough to do because we see
things on social media, and we react, and
it’s tough to shift people’s perspective
once they think something. Chaos is just
something we’re going to have to live with.
I mean, if you look at the last three years,
Putin got what he wanted in a number of cases.
Our trust in the system is not going to change
automatically on, you know, mid-November
of 2020. It’s going to take some time to
regain trust in the system, if we ever do.
SIERRA: Looking ahead, not just to 2020,
but to the future state of our democracy can be...
rough. New norms are being established every day
as technology races ahead and we struggle
to understand how our world has changed.
2016 can feel like old news, but it’s only
been a few years since this all went down.
It’s still a fresh bruise. And the
attacks are going to keep coming.
ROSENBERGER: So my hope, and trying to be
positive on this topic is sometimes hard,
but my hope is that one of the things it taught
the world is that democracy is something we can't
take for granted. I think that is something
we have been doing for a little bit too long,
especially in democracies that had been considered
to be consolidated. We had this idea that
democracy would be just self-perpetuating. And
we stopped investing in some of the really core
aspects of our democracy.
SIERRA:
There’s a lot more to learn about election
security, so check out the show notes for
this episode at CFR.org. And while you’re there,
have a look at our Candidate tracker. It’s an easy
way to see where each candidate stands on foreign
policy. We would also like to take this moment and
encourage you to register to vote. Your voice
matters. Visit vote.gov, and make sure you are
good to go. Please subscribe to Why It Matters
on apple podcasts, spotify, or wherever you
get your podcasts. Your feedback makes this show
better, so leave us a review or send us an email
at whyitmatters@cfr.org. If you dig the show, you
can show us some love by telling your friends or
rating us with five stars. Why It Matters is a
production of the Council on Foreign Relations.
The show is created and produced by Jeremy
Sherlick, Asher Ross, and me, Gabrielle Sierra.
Our sound designer is Markus Zakaria. Robert
McMahon is our Managing Editor, and Doug Halsey
is our Chief Digital Officer. Christian Wolan is
our Product Manager. Original music was composed
by Ceiri Torjussen. Special thanks for this
episode go to Richard Haass, Jeff Reinke, and
Adam Segal. For Why It Matters, this is Gabrielle
Sierra, signing off. See you on election day!